they elected the least cognitive capable
politician we've ever seen except baby
fetterman and they put him in the job
that has the greatest cognitive demand
of maybe any job you could even imagine
the president of the United States and
the highest importance
and that's who they put in the job the
person who we can all see has the lowest
cognitive ability for any president so
far
now if that election is close let's say
with Trump or any anybody else and it
probably will be it'll be really close
does that not prove that our opinions
have been assigned to us as opposed to
we looked at the information and made up
our own mind I would say that if we have
a close election and Biden is one of the
candidates
and it still ends up razor razor close
that we've proven beyond a shadow of a
doubt that whatever you thought was
happening wasn't happening I.E informed
citizens making informed decisions that
are translated by the election system
into the accurate result whatever's
happening it isn't that and that's where
we're heading for so I guess we'll find
out
but I think the point that Francis was
getting out with you something I've I
saw a graph on on Twitter today
um which showed the average age of
politicians over the last two centuries
in the United States and you you can't
you can barely see the line because it's
close to Vertical right it's it's really
increased particularly in the last 60
years
um it's it and and it's it's bipartisan
by the way look at look at Mitch
McConnell there's another video of him
struggling to stay stand up straight and
talk at the same time this week has been
good bipartisan cooperation
and a string of uh
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to you
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
yeah you know and I worry that there's a
reason and this is the banker part of me
so I used to work for a bank for many
years before I was doing this kind of
stuff and when I worked for the bank
they had a rule that you couldn't take
uh was it four days off in a row or no
you had to take that much that's that's
what it was you had to take a vacation
so the bank wouldn't let you skip your
vacations for too long and the reason
was that one of the ways that people
would rob the bank from the inside you
know an Insider kind of thing is they
had to be there to cover up things on a
continuous basis so if you made them
stay away from the office their crimes
would would pop up because somebody's
covering for their job
so I wonder if it's a coincidence that
in a world where we don't trust anybody
to not be corrupt at the top anymore
that the old people can't retire because
then you'd find out what they were up to
imagine for example Joe Biden retires
just as we're finding out you know what
he might have been up to with Hunter by
if he stays president he can pardon
people and he can scare people away from
investigating if Mitch McConnell stays
in his position
uh anybody who might want to say look
into his business is not going to want
to do it because it's a political death
sentence he's powerful so when I see
people who are way past their expiration
date and they stay in sometimes it's
because they don't want to lose the
majority but I worry that it's the bank
reason that is the moment they were out
of that job other people could figure
out what's been going on all the time
they were in there so that that's that's
my worry
foreign